[Music]
do do
do do do do do
do
[Music]
do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do do do do do do
hey everybody
hope you're all doing well
hope that pride has treated you well
are we talking about the dress I wore
the ren Fair
yeah
somebody
um somebody very very special gave me
that
thank you Mrs wiggle this one I like
this one quite fond of it
part of what I like about this one is
it's actually quite secure but it looks
like I'm about to fall out of it I have
fun with that
the nails I need to figure out what I'm
gonna do with this one now that they've
started coming off these ones are still
there
so I got my my gender fluid colors
flying
which
yeah I'm I'm proud of that
very vava Voom hmm
thank you Gozer
yes a happy Pride
I hope you've all had a nice Pride so
far
and we'll continue to and that the world
will not immediately go to hell as soon
as we enter the next month although it
hasn't really stopped going to hell
whatever
yay for gay
so
we have the Superman news
I uh I did put a short out on that
already so I don't really have too much
to add I don't know either of these
actors I mean they look the parts you
know going by headshots
yeah I have been putting out more stuff
lately actually like
it's funny I might have
I might have
um bumped
um
the
uh planned Wednesday video for tomorrow
which is
um the finale of flux the take to Doctor
Who review I might have bumped that
another week and done the spider-verse
thing on Wednesday
um except I don't even remember who it
was I don't even know if they're a
regular commentator but somebody had
asked in the
comment section on the Illuminati video
you know what happened to the take two
review I'm like it'll be out next week
promise and because I'd made a promise
to that one person I was like
well I can't bump the Wednesday video
again and so you guys got an extra one
you got a Monday video
definitely don't expect that on a
regular basis
because
since I'm still I still can't afford to
Outsource my editing so this is a lot of
extra work
ah
I recorded an episode for my podcast
about my favorite queer celebrities
you're on the list oh Jason
I
I don't know how well I count as a
celebrity but I I will take the uh take
the compliment whether or not I get
recognized is heavily dependent on where
we are I get recognized at Gallifrey won
uh
decently reliably
but outside of that
not so much
oh uh reminder while I will try to keep
up with the chat
I make no
um promises and the way to guarantee
that I will see your comment and or
answer your question would be to do it
as a super chat which will also get you
a heart from me
of the potion vial theme going thank you
uh I I this is what I treated myself to
at
uh the ren Fair because unfortunately
um the all the entries for um
excuse me
um all the entries for the
um
archery tournament were full up so I
couldn't win that although
I did still get yet another Master
Archer ribbon which you get for hitting
a bullseye because I did still shoot at
the range
so
regardless
except for when I get mistaken for Riley
yeah that happened that happened several
times uh my first year there
that
I really don't think we looked that
similar
oh wow
she and I still get a kick out of that
though
yes Miss Wicked Wolf I know you do keep
up with all my stuff
Garfield turned 45 this month have you
ever go have you ever gone back and
looked at like the very first Garfield
strips
he looks so weird
compared to how he looks now it's really
strange
all right the um the rent the
renaissance fair was fun it was raining
um so I had to bring
the umbrella
um my kiddo came with me and so I was
basically on umbrella Duty I had my
rainbow umbrella so I had the the big
gay umbrella
um
so
actually made it I think it's like
sometimes it would dial down enough that
we didn't need the umbrella and then I
it would start up again and I'd
um I'd put it
up
but uh I would be like extend the
umbrella like yay
oh Jen past midnight in the UK now it's
my birthday happy birthday Jen
um like early Simpson's weird actually
weirder Chandler see the thing is you
can look at early Simpsons the weirdest
thing about early Simpsons is honestly
the way they move and animate the
designs you can look at those and go
okay I see how that got refined you look
at the early design of Garfield and it's
like
how how is that where we started how is
that where this whole thing began
I haven't really watched too much
Garfield stuff in a while who got the
Family Guy Garfield his nine lives a bit
stuck in my head now I don't remember
that bit but I'll tell you what
Garfield's Nine Lives is an excellent
special I like the Garfield specials
there's a number of them I still like I
like Garfield Halloween I like Garfield
Christmas I like Garfield's nine lives a
lot
this they're just good
yeah even the very first one here comes
Garfield and like the music's real good
on those two the early ones they got
they had Lou Rawls singing these things
oh it was great
a city Here Comes got field oh you
better look out
Here Comes Garfield
great I love that
I just had a viewing experience that
made me feel really bad for funimations
adaptation writers oh
I'm curious now
there's a bit where a character who
can't read constructs a message by
drawing images that phonetically make up
the word they want to communicate but it
only works in Japanese oh
yep yep no that uh that would complicate
things
Elijah Anderson thank you very much for
the Super Chat happy Pride big fan of
yours loved your last video on the abuse
involved in spider-verse thank you for
that I didn't love making it but I'm
glad it's it's being taken well I was
saddened when I read the article yeah
you and me too
like the thing is I can't
I can't necessarily say I was surprised
and I might not even have done something
if it hadn't been able to lay out
exactly the way in which the thing was
mismanaged
because
being able to see and then to reiterate
um on video for folks the
specific way in which the management was
just deeply disrespectful because look
first of all crunch is never okay
it's just it's not
it's just not but there is a difference
I think
in terms of the situation there is a
difference that is worth noting between
a project where
everyone's been trying and working and
moving it forward but like they're just
up against the deadline
there's still probably been some
mismanagement but there's a difference
between that and going in telling your
animators don't bring me this unfinished
stuff make it fully render fully
finished then bring it in then I'll
decide if we're using it that is so
disrespectful
and what's really annoying is
uh Chris Miller Phil Ward like they
started an animation they they should
know this
it's real
it's really awful and and like the thing
is I suspect that they haven't done this
on all their stuff I suspect that this
is something that like this is complete
speculation on my part I suspect this is
something they do now that they have the
cloud to get away with it I am pretty
sure on Clone High the original airing
of that they did not have the clout to
get away with telling people to bring
them finished stuff before they could
decide to cut it but it just works
better for them and so they make people
do it despite the fact that is it
literally a waste of everyone else's
time and effort
anyway
just Googled it Garfield looks weird but
John looks so much weirder yeah like the
the whole
the whole aesthetic of Garfield Garfield
got a lot more cartoonish as it went on
those early ones though they are odd
huh
I went to my first Pride got to see my
uh girlfriend the most relaxed she's
been well dressed slightly Femme and
wearing a trans flag around her waist oh
Cara
that's wonderful I'm really glad to hear
that
am I gonna say you see Indiana Jones of
Destiny probably my mother wants to see
it so I'll probably go with her
uh we'll answer some of your trial of
time lure questions via big finish in
regards to if the Perry mind swap thing
actually happened yes but it's more
complicated than that oh like that's the
that's the exact kind of thing big
finish Lobster
pick up and run with
so how do I feel about the ongoing saga
of shows being canceled in a race for
tax purposes I hate it
I hate it this is the system that we've
built and this is how stuff is
incentivized and
the main thing that really irritates me
about it is
you know I think there was proper and
deserved righteous outrage at
HBO doing it
I'd really hoped that the pushback on
that would dissuade others from doing
the same thing
but I think the thing is
that unless you were subscribed to HBO
Max
for that one specific thing that they've
now gotten rid of or canceled or taken
off the servers
odds are you still have a subscription
to Max
now
and so ultimately
from their perspective
like everybody complained everybody
bitched
and what probably actually happened in
terms of how many customers they lost
probably wasn't that many probably
nowhere near how much money they saved
by taking the stuff off the servers
and so what we're dealing with is
basically the
the rest of the entertainment industry
is kind of catching up to video games
because
um
so much stuff that's normal now
the
um carving off of what used to be
standard content as initially DLC and
then later micro transactions
um things like alternate costumes which
used to be a fun thing you could unlock
now you have to pay extra money for it
um things like that
it's so normal now and it used to be
that that stuff either got mocked or
shouted down but the thing is
either because people felt like well I
just won't participate in that stuff
or
um
you know they just they just wanted the
rest of what the game had to offer
regardless
those kinds of controversies rarely
actually hurt the sales
of the games loot boxes was a little
different because the Uproar on that got
even worse but basically the lesson that
the video game industry learned over the
last 20 years was
Gamers will complain
very very loudly
and then buy it anyways
and unfortunately I think the rest of
the entertainment industry is reaching a
similar conclusion at the very least
when it comes to streaming platforms
less so when it comes to something like
movie tickets or you know newly launched
shows or whatever so it's not across the
board but specifically in regards to the
streaming platforms I think they are
coming to a similar conclusion of we
will do these things we'll take stuff
off of it we'll make it no longer
available we will strip away the ability
to see these things
and people will [__] about it
but they also won't cancel their
subscriptions
and they're right so
eh
am I going to see the next Hunger Games
movie based on the prequel book probably
not uh Louise I actually haven't read
any of the books I only saw the first
two movies so no that's not really uh
high on my priority list
let's see
early Garfield looks like a grumpy cat
with a face shaped like balls
uh you're not wrong
do you think there's a difference
between schlock and Pulp
um
if there is it's a hair splitting kind
of difference it's like personal
definitions for all intents and purposes
not really
I love Renaissance Fairs I haven't been
to one in over a decade oh Toronto
Eternal sailor Earth I recommend you get
to one I haven't even been to that many
I've been to the ones around here where
I am uh in Vermont but they're not even
like that big they're not like the big
huge ones and all these things it's nice
I just like them
plus I win the archery tournament so
uh I just got my girlfriend fully caught
up on Doctor Who so now I'm happy I have
someone in my life to talk about all the
news too that is always nice to have
isn't it
I like Heath Cliff I never read Heath
Cliff I remember the cartoon though
been enjoying the Babylon 5 podcast I'm
curious which character has grown on you
the most and why
I mean probably Franklin but that has to
do with how much I really hated him in
the first season like I really did not
like him at all so he he kind of had
nowhere to go butt up
I got to share this Pride with my mom as
our first prideout together was a great
time ah it's great Bex
speaking of Pride I requested an
asexuality t-shirt for my birthday hope
I get it
fingers crossed
DreamWorks made a bad move releasing
their movie the same day style of
Destiny is that the teenage Kraken one
I don't know what DreamWorks is up to
uh are being destroyed for tax purposes
is some dystopian [__] I mean
yeah
hmm
did camcorder have Greens in 1994 and
the time travel story I'm reading
there's a plot point about the character
not being able to show some footage
because they didn't have a VCR
um
some
models would have
a view screen would not have been on all
camcorder models in 94.
some would some would have that
I think by then but it wouldn't have
been standard
and that's me guesstimating in my in my
head on the timeline there
if you want to Deep dive in Garfield I
suggest YouTube channel super eye patch
wolf I've heard of that channel I don't
think I've ever watched them do I like
iced tea only if it's unsweetened
I find iced tea to be way too sweet most
of the time
what did you mean last week when you
said the studios take their quips super
seriously
um
I don't remember the context in which I
said that so I don't know
like you gotta realize when I'm when I'm
shooting
something unscripted
um the odds of me remembering it later
aren't High
my city isn't holding their pride this
year until October so I decided to go do
I drag Bingo instead and pine after my
best friends like the useless me and I
am oh
always I hope you mean that as um
as like a uh
a mood label and not like a genuine
thought of what you are because you're
not useless
uh
I wouldn't want the valyr to return in
the TV series if only because big finish
gave him a Perfect final appearance in
the eighth doctor time War series oh all
right
I mean I just don't really care
you're talking about why Studios
couldn't Market pulp stories oh okay so
the thing is the quippiness that is in
a lot of modern day films and people
like attribute it to Marvel but it's
it's kind of all over the place right
now it's in there as part of like
it's like it's in there like it's part
of a checklist
and
the thing about pulp is part of Pulp
stories is they are honestly usually
over serious or at the very least taking
something that is a little bit like
really and you know this is true of Paul
Boon schlock and camp and all that is
trading something seriously when it's
like what
the thing about quippy nature that
studios are very very fond of because
it's on the checklist for elements that
you can drop into basically in a movie
and like oh real big popular movies have
quippy dialogue oh let's drop this in oh
gee Rick I don't know why I turned into
Morty there I don't know
anyways
um
you know when when you're at a point
where you're trying to have that kind of
taking things less Siri seriously
because the quips basically acknowledge
that the situation is maybe not worth
being taken fully seriously and if
you're gonna do pulp or schlock or Camp
right it needs to be treated seriously
if you treat it like a joke that's when
it becomes a spoof or a Pastiche or a
parody and stops being the thing
our philosophy is
favorite Donna moment
mine is a wasp that's giant
um oh gosh I don't know
honestly I just like her on the on the
hill with wolf
I just that just gives me a real warm
feeling
that is that is one of my favorite
quotes from Babylon five uh Dharma
yeah what do you want you moon-faced
Assassin of joy
Lando's great like londo's terrible like
a horrible person but Lando's great as a
character
yes it is a mood uh they're dating each
other and I'm too afraid to ask about a
throuple oh
polyamory is becoming more common
especially among the queer Community I'm
just saying
if you if you can find people
who are comfortable with it
or For Whom It comes naturally
that are going to bounce well off each
other and be comfortable with each other
regardless of the specifics of their and
of their own Dynamic
um but just like collectively just sort
of the piece fits together well
multiple partners is a real nice thing
I'm just saying it's a real nice thing
but in re-watching Joel Schumacher
Batman and Robin lately most because of
Arnold's ice puns and Uma poison ivy to
cheer myself up
I mean if that does it for you power to
you
please do this as Morty I don't know if
I can actually do a Morty voice very
well
um but
uh hey Rick what if we get recast
because our voice actor is a monster
like that's not quite right I like I
haven't paid attention partly because
like I've only seen like three episodes
of
Rick and Morty cause
it's just
I just didn't really like it I hated the
characters ultimately
um
so I don't know how well I could even do
Justin roiland's voices I do know that
like they've already recast him for the
part he played on solar opposites which
is on Hulu and the way I don't watch
this but I heard about it the way they
did that
they had like the characters are like in
a bar and somebody throws a dart and it
hits the character that was voiced by
royland in the throat
and they like patch him up but it
permanently changes his voice and so the
new voice actor isn't even trying to
sound like Justin Roiland
I love that like I think that should
become the way that they do this uh
hmm
do I prefer a Futurama over Rick and
Morty well by default I like Futurama I
don't like Rick and Morty so you
yeah
that said I don't know how high on my
priority list watching the new Futurama
stuff is going to be like it just
oh well
hmm
excuse me
could I do an Uma Thurman poison IV
impression it was very may waste it was
very May West wasn't it
poison
ivy
yeah
oh
I can't remember too many of our lines
wait they brought back a Futurama not
yet but there's a trailer out there it's
gonna be on Hulu
who is the character that many find
annoying that I enjoy uh
[Music]
uh I know a lot of people find Nardo
annoying
um
I quite like him well not his first
parents to be fair uh
[Music]
polyamory's hard work solo polyamory is
a valid thing too oh absolutely like
there's a lot of different ways for that
to
um play out and and to manifest
but you know
for some of us it's uh
uh makes a lot of sense
just saying
uh do I think Anna Beth from Percy
Jackson the books has a Southern accent
I've never read those books
so I have no opinion
I love Jewel from Far state but so many
hater
um
she was a little iffy when she first
showed up Jewel grew on me norant he's
the one I can't stand I really don't
like her
the time travel story is set in 2013
even though it's written in 1994 the
funniest thing about this version of
2013 is they mentioned Macaulay Culkin
is the new James Bond
that okay that's got to be a joke then
because
like they never would he's not even
like they wouldn't test an American
I was gonna say he's not even English to
be fair they cast on Australia in that
one time but it was literally that one
time
um my mom and stepdad are polyamorous
her girlfriend is coming to visit today
I love watching how happy they are oh
that's wonderful
I know King of the Hill was meant to be
coming back will be very interesting to
see if they'll recast Luanne I would
imagine they would
laughs
they're going to they were going to cast
Adam West's Bond
that would have been interesting
I'll take back to the future of a Rick
and Morty any day
I'm back to the future is legitimately
great Rick and Morty is it just
I just really like I
even fully setting aside
the issues with Roiland
um
I just I watched those three episodes
and I'm like I can see how this is
clever I can see how this is witty I can
see how this is intelligent but boy do I
not want to spend time with these people
and like I also if I can be
a little bit mean about royland I can't
stand his voices
like even the one voice he did on
Gravity Falls I really didn't like
he's just real grading to the ear at
least to mine and I'm sure that's like
that would come back with a working as
intended note these are supposed to be
annoying characters well congratulations
I guess
you annoyed me
yeah I think it's a joke like they say
uh you'd not think he'd work in the role
but he does yeah so okay so clearly they
knew
Supreme
Omega thank you kindly hope you're well
thoughts on the term rainbow capitalism
because for me when corporations were
the pride flag I suspect they only care
about the money well first of all
Supreme Omega uh of course they only
care about the money
like yes factually they only care about
the money that so like don't even don't
even question that don't even doubt that
yes of course they do here's what I have
said in the past about rainbow
capitalism and I do
stand by this although this is not a
hill I'm prepared to die on
while rainbow capitalism is
fundamentally insufficient especially
these days in a time when queer people
trans people especially are being
actively legislated against oppressed
and attacked sometimes physically simply
for existing just
putting up a rainbow flag is wholly
insufficient
it's also worth noting that a lot of
these corporations
um will back
um
politicians who push for anti-queer
legislation now
I was going to say to be fair not to be
fair but for full context they generally
back those politicians because they back
people who will free up as much
regulation as possible who tend to be
Republicans who also tend to have a lot
of overlap so they don't back these
people because they're anti-queer they
back them for
the money for selfish Financial
regulatory tax uh law based reasons and
what those people will do on those kinds
of fronts and those people just also
happen to be anti-queer
so understanding all that that these
corporations are not our friends
they're definitely not our allies
there is a tiny Silver Lining of value
to Rainbow capitalism and I've said this
elsewhere before but I'll say it again
these are companies and corporations
with entire departments
multiple salary people whose entire job
is keeping a pulse on the direction of
culture and trying to look like they're
on the right side of it
so while infuriatingly behind closed
doors they back politicians who do harm
us again for the money not because they
are us but it is still what happens the
end result is the same while behind
closed doors they do that the fact that
they don't do that publicly the fact
that they will publicly support us means
that their
well educated well-versed teams of
people believe that supporting us and
siding with us is the right side to be
on they think we're gonna win
and I do take some comfort in that
doesn't mean I want to throw a bunch of
money at Disney or
Target or anything else because they
have a rainbow flag up no absolutely not
but I do still see
some value in it being there
not a ton
and not enough
but some
so
that's sort of where I'm at and I don't
think rainbow capitalism is I don't
think rainbow capitalism is worth at
this point getting that worked up about
because it is so far down the priority
list of [__] we need to be dealing with
um I think it was more valid as an
argument say three or four years ago
when we weren't
when we were on the upswing you know
following
um the gay marriage ruling
but since then
like
this this is not a good use of our
energy
uh
seems from the leaked set pictures that
Walter Peck is back in the next
Ghostbusters film oh God damn it
why
there is no need oh I think I even heard
that before
how do we stop Democrat politicians from
going Centrist depends on where they are
like some of them you're more Southern
Democrats if you can get them to
Centrist you're lucky because you have
people like Joe manchin who are just
Republican light
um
honestly you run Progressive candidates
against them and you vote for those
people
so that
um if you're very lucky the progressive
will get in
um in worst case scenario if the
progressive still does well
then maybe the uh Democratic does win
will go oh
I shouldn't be scorning their that side
of the thing
that's a broad General thought though
Paramount's also removing stuff they
took down Prodigy oh yeah no I saw I saw
that news and my immediate thought was
Jesse's gonna be ripped [__] and she was
uh
clearly they care about the money but I
personally feel the more we see rainbows
in stores the more normalized it becomes
yeah there's some value there as well
actually I did the math in my head
calcium was only 32 33 in 2013 even if
he had been right for the role do you
think he'd be too young for a bond I
mean
at that point in time no not not for
that mentality that uh would have been
had at that time because you know they
had Craig
in place by then but
um you know there's a reason why they're
looking for a 30-something Bond now they
want someone who can stick around for as
many movies as possible
so
no I could see that having been the
mentality then too
uh
companies should be always Beyond pride
month I mean
companies should be dismantled and
stripped down and broken apart and not
allowed to get as big as they are and
they shouldn't be allowed to put money
into politics
that's what should really happen I
shouldn't have to worry about whether or
not a company is an ally honestly it
shouldn't matter they shouldn't have
that kind of pull or that kind of Swing
or that kind of power in politics they
just shouldn't
yeah
the season of tallasso pulled a crappy
Trope of character in a woman loving
woman relationship got back with the man
she was originally with
in the second season and everyone
demonized the woman loving woman ship
that's shitty
that's a shame
uh did you get to see Trevor Noah's bit
about the idea of Idris Elba being
floated as the next one I might have I
don't remember it now
but oh well
favorite current serving governor in the
U.S
I don't know I don't pay attention to
Governors that much I don't like mine
I've not voted for my Governor once and
he's on I think his third term I don't I
don't like the Vermont governor
can Jinx and Arcane be read as autistic
um well John vinyls thank you for the
Super Chat first of all
really the best person to ask as so far
as I am aware
I don't have autism
I don't think
I don't have a diagnosis let's go with
that
um
um and I don't I don't have
as much
uh experience in trying to do
neurodivergent readings
on characters
so I don't feel super comfortable
answering that what I will say is
um Jinx is definitely a wash in trauma
like she is she is walking trauma
but if we were to narrow down on the
front end of the show
first three episodes when she's young
um
possibly she's certainly lacking in a
lot of coping skills but that's not
necessarily an autistic trait I mean
like there can be overlap
so like without again reiterating I'm
probably not the person who should be
answering that I would think
possibly but I actually think it gets
potentially problematic reading her that
way especially looking at
um you know her early segments but again
like I also like not really my place to
say
uh I was so happy to see the lesbian
representation overall I thought the
season was good they just screwed over
that character big time that's that's
still a shame
all I care about with rainbow capitalism
is the people who get so angry about the
rainbow and go completely insane over it
I mean
that is uh its own special kind of
thing isn't it
I don't think it makes sense for anyone
other than a white British man to play
James Bond given he's supposed to
represent
that's why I want to get rid of the
character
I mean I think it depends on whether or
not you want to try and update and
revise the character now James Bond as
he existed in the 60s being a
representation of not just
Britain but specifically
British Colonial
um
oppression basically he was an
embodiment of the Empire yeah he
absolutely should be white but if you're
gonna reboot again which you have to
with the way
um
uh no time to die ended God was crap
I don't get why people like that one I
really don't
but anyways
um if you're gonna revise bond in some
way you could reshape him in a way that
that would make that work I would say if
they were ever going to like make bond
into a period piece like set it back in
the 60s again I do agree with you
um he should be white because of the
specific era of Britain that he embodies
it like because the thing is Bond
especially at that time embodies a lot
of the worst
of the British Empire of colonialism and
[Music]
yeah he should be white
but you know in terms of newer stuff
moving forward depends on what they do
with it
driver Noah did the best Oscars joke in
years back in 2019. I don't remember I
don't remember much of the Oscars these
days to be honest
who is the best Joker so far I think
Heath Ledger Joaquin Phoenix tie for the
top uh nobody get into a pedantic
argument with me about oh well he's
technically not the Joker piss off
Jerome uh Jerome from Gotham was
excellent I really loved him
that's not to knock
um Heath Ledger Joaquin Phoenix Heath
Ledger was great Joaquin Phoenix
put in the work he was the best part of
a not particularly good movie
um
and that's limiting it to live action of
course
because the the instant the instant you
go to animated you you bring in Mark
Hamill and everybody else loses
Ian Fleming model the character of James
Bond at least probably on Roald Dahl
yeah no I knew that I knew that goes her
hmm
damn I'm late but it's for good reasons
no worry uh amber like we're just
rambling about whatever comes up so
no uh no problem
James Bonds possibly code name anyway so
it's possible anyone could play the
character again that kind of depends
because like
Skyfall Daniel Craig's Bond you could
make the argument of bond being a code
name for some of the others but honestly
it doesn't hold up very well Daniel
Craig bond is a dude named James Bond
like he just is that's the way Skyfall
is handled when he goes back to his
ancestral home and the games keeper
calls him James like he's like James
Bonds his name that's just a dude named
James Bond the previous era oh I say
error the previous multiple eras of
James Bond prior to that like there was
an argument to be made that you know
maybe it's a code name
um there were even certain hints to that
effect like George lazyby had the name I
bet this never happened to the other guy
implying that he might have just taken
on uh the
uh you know the the identity but then
there was stuff like for your eyes only
which opens in a way that only makes
sense if the Roger Moore James Bond is
the same guy as
um
the George Lazenby
James Bond so like it's weird uh
continuity in that show is very weird
uh Hamill's my Joker Mark Hamill's Joker
was yeah he was good stuff hang on a
second let me
let me check something here just a
moment
[Music]
um
Talk Amongst yourselves
[Music]
and now that's not what I want
ah here we go
all right I was trying to find myself a
uh
here we go I was trying to find myself a
good Joker bet
dear friends
today is the day the Clown
and he cries not for the passing of one
man
but for the death of a dream
a dream that he would someday taste the
ultimate victory over his hated enemy
for it was the Batman who made me the
happy soul I am today
how I agonized of the perfect way to
thank him for that
perhaps a cyanide pies in the face or an
exploding whoopee cushion playfully
planted in the Batmobile
but those dreams were dashed by the
Weasley little gunsel sitting there in
our midst the Cowardly insignificant
Garnet who probably got lucky when
Batman slipped on the Slime Trail this
loser left behind him this mound of
diseased hyena filled who's not victim
like the dead from my spots
but I digress
the time for sorrow has passed it's time
to look to a future
filled with smiles and I'll be smiling
again just as soon as we take that man
there and slap him in that box there and
roll him into that vat of acid there
Hammer was great I enjoy doing Hamilton
Joker Jerome not Jeremiah uh correct uh
I don't like Jeremiah at all I think
Jerome's awesome though
I always think of Jack when I think of
Joker he like I feel like Jack Nicholson
gets lost a little bit in the
conversation now which is a shame
because he's a he is a good Joker
where do I get a load of me
ah
backs two dollars Super Chat that for
our mutual love of Mark Hamill as the
Joker oh thank you very much Discord yes
I will check that in just a second
Carolyn
uh
the main character in its culture book I
want you to read uh is partially a
deconstruction of bond I believe that'll
be interesting
uh yeah Susie James like especially uh
freaking uh Goldfinger it's bad it's
real it's real bad
gamer Jamie hope you're having a good
month it'd be good to see a trans woman
of color who's bisexual with a
girlfriend just to piss off all the
conservatives who said James Bond should
always be a man well I mean they kind of
did that because they had a woman take
over the 007 designation in no time to
die not that he helped the movie still
wasn't very good
anyways
um I gotta pop over to the Discord
reminder Council of Geeks Discord is a
patreon exclusive perk so if you go to
patreon.com councilofgeeks support at
two dollars or more you can get access
to the Discord but I gotta pop over
there and see what questions they have
brought up
all right we got a few
you said you could maybe be a
pro-capitalist if we had regulations to
keep it from exploiting people too much
do you think it's actually possible for
a society to maintain regulation like
that long term I'm of the opinion that
regulations like that will always get
rolled back eventually since rich people
don't want them in rich people will
always be able to use their wealth to
influence government policy well two
things about that relatively quickly
the first is
one of the things that I would very
happily Implement is a maximum wage uh
that would do a lot to cap the
accumulation of wealth but
um beyond that the thing is while that
is not an invalid criticism
um it's basically in some form not that
exact wording but some form true move
pretty much every system whatever the
guard rails are that are that are in
place meant to keep any political or
social system in line and going the
right way can always be dismantled by
the people who have power in a
capitalist system that happens to be the
people with money in other systems it
might be the people who hold certain
political positions or both
um so like that's just you're not wrong
but that's also just a criticism of
humans
and any system is prone to that kind of
problem because no matter what any
political thinker tells you no system is
self-correcting every system has
problems and needs guard rails to to
keep that system from just falling into
uh the worst version of itself but the
guard rails can always be dismantled no
matter what the system is
your last video about the spiderverse
reminded me of something I was wandering
back at the start of the writer strike
do you think paying to see a movie that
was written by writers who were writing
during the strike I.E scabs would be
moral morally comparable to crossing a
picket line
um
I don't
I don't really know I mean part of it is
logistically I don't know
how clear it's gonna be when that does
happen because so far as I'm aware like
there isn't anything like that going on
right now most of the stuff that is
still moving forward is was you know
stuff that already had exemptions from
the union like Jesse's still prepping uh
identities
but you know she's not a union writer
and even if the uh actors strike she's
consulted with her crew like will you
want to continue to work or will you
want to stop and they'd be like no we're
okay because it's a very small
production so it's got exemptions from
the normal requirements of the Union in
terms of pay and all the rest of the
stuff anyways so I
but like to throw the logistics out and
just deal with the philosophical heart
of what you're asking
um
it'd be it'd certainly be in the same
zip code whether it be comparable I
I don't know
it be connected certainly
uh there's a bit in one of the culture
books where a character mentions the
fact that on her home orbital there's a
group of people who spend all their time
living in the woods Gathering wild food
so they can occasionally climb up and
then Skydive off these floating blimp
creatures that live there the culture is
okay with letting them live there since
they're not hurting anyone do you think
that kind of thing is something that's
unfortunately lacking in treks depiction
of near utopian society all the people
who'd want to take advantage of of a
lack of social restriction or need to
work to live take uh take up strange
seemingly alternative Lifestyles
um no but only because the lens through
which we view Star Trek it wouldn't make
sense for that to come up very much
because basically
I think the nature of Star Trek as a
narrative certainly allows for that but
since the stories of Star Trek are
pretty much always on diplomatic bases
or more often than not ships that are on
a specific mission
they're not going to be crude by those
kinds of people so I don't think it's a
prop like Trek does lack that a little
bit but not in the world I think I have
an easy time believing that kind of
thing happens within the world of Star
Trek it's just The Narrative of Star
Trek doesn't really allow for that to
come up you know with the kinds of
settings that they use and um plots that
they have in motion
uh if you had to make an educated guess
why is crunch still a thing when all the
science says that more than 50 hours of
work is going to suffer from diminishing
returns
um well there's a couple reasons and uh
the the first is is that
um no matter what they say ultimately
people make the decisions
um the executives they are human beings
and they act off emotion just as much as
anybody else emotion that is largely
driven by a desire for money and they do
look at numbers to justify that but
emotionally they believe
that it is better to squeeze what they
have out of the resources they have than
to
um
then to hire more people or wait longer
and there's the external pressure of the
shareholders which is why delays are
rare
um unless it's really gone off the rails
but like beyond that the excuses that
companies will give will be like well
like these this is a creative field we
could hire more people but then like we
got to bring them up to speed on
everything going on make sure they're in
line with the vision like it let let's
just work with who we have
and there's all it also gets to be a
slightly weird dynamic where
you have to bring in temp people by and
large
um because most projects don't need that
big as projects that end up crunching
their staff
they need to be ramped up in the tail
end of production which is usually where
the crunch happens but that means as a
practicality hiring temporary workers
which are often seen as less skilled
that's not always accurate but it's
often how they're seen
um and also harder to control because
they can leave at they have a much
higher ability to leave at any moment
um because they're not under salary now
that doesn't mean that they will there's
a good chance they still need the work
because they are crunched under
capitalism same as everybody else but
they're theoretically harder to control
which is part of why especially in the
video game industry they will dangle the
promise of permanent employee meant in
front of 10 people on the occasions when
they actually hire them but like
there's no good reason why crunch is
still a thing there are lots of stupid
[__] reasons but there's no good
reason
um because it can even come down to
something as as
horrifying as the people in charge being
like well I had to do this so what are
you complaining about which is I hate
that I hate that so much
and you hear that in so many places you
hear that like with student loans well I
have to pay off my student loan debt I'm
like
so you know well first of all you
probably don't know how bad it is maybe
it was bad for you but it probably
wasn't this bad but let's set that aside
assume for a minute that it was why
would you want that for somebody else
you sadistic [__] I'm swearing more this
stream than I usually like to but
uh given the broken state of capitalism
ah funny we went there if you had to
make an educated guess what would be a
pragmatic solution to bring the worst
excesses of it to heal I don't know
because
um
ah
it's going to be incredibly difficult to
roll back most of the stuff that
um has gone completely out of hand and
uh people won't let it happen okay if we
want to be cold and pragmatic about it
Eat the Rich
I know it's like a motto but seriously
we probably wouldn't even have to eat
all of them
two maybe three you know just to send
the message that we're not messing
around
I might do it
thought experiment you are the host of a
taste of Vermont party what are you
serving difficulty no maple syrup
um
okay well you're gonna have
you're gonna have
plenty of stuff with cheese specially
extra sharp cheddar Cabot
um because that stuff's amazing you're
gonna serve cider
um to drink
um you're gonna go with you're gonna go
with bacon and it will be Maples Maple
smoked because you said no maple syrup
not no Maple anything so we'll get Maple
smoked
bacon
in there
um
that's sort of the stuff that is coming
off in the top of my head but
you know a good fresh salad we get we
get good greens up here
uh I'd probably have to do kale just
because it's it's native around here I
don't like it but you know some fried up
bits of kale I can't like I'm not good
at full meal planning but you know
there's sort of your amuse amuse Bouche
or whatever how do I deal with people in
my friend group saying stuff like yeah
crunch won't be a thing when animators
get replaced by AI because they complain
about crunch too much
um I don't know it depends on their uh
reason for saying that when you get a
professional job you'll learn that
crunch is just a part of life oh okay so
they're [__] only forehead and made
a smoke out about this this may just
mean they're new
and all crunch complaints just well down
to people complaining about working
overtime at happy employees countering
that by saying they were paid over time
which could be worse
ah
all right let's run down
um you say replaced by AI as if we
should allow that to happen we shouldn't
we should be preventing that too we
could do both
crunch is a part of life it shouldn't be
it shouldn't be even if it is it
shouldn't be
you used to be able to maintain a home
on a part-time job a very
um
uh humble home but you used to being be
able to maintain a home on a part-time
job or on minimum wage you can pay a
mortgage on minimum wage
you can't now
so don't tell me like it's just a part
of life it's not supposed to be only
four animators spoke about it maybe that
may just mean they're new they're not
they were vetted by vulture and if you
read the original article they note that
three out of the four were Veterans of
the industry who made specific
comparisons to stuff they've already
endured on other on other things and
noting that this was worse
like all of these basically boil down to
I don't want to have to think about how
capitalism is destroying somebody's life
and people will have a lot of reasons
for not wanting to acknowledge that
whether it be they themselves are
consumers and they want to continue to
consume whatever the thing is it may
just be uh philosophical exhaustion if
they just don't have the processing
power anymore or it could be that
capitalism is doing just fine by them
and so it's a I'm just going to lean
into the fact that I'm swearing tonight
it's a [__] you got mine thing could be
any number of things how do you deal
with them I don't know
the thing is
and I look I'm gonna say this strictly
for myself this is not advice
but I'm not friends with anyone who
would say that
so I don't have advice for what you
should do about people in your friends
group who say those things
because I'm not friends with people who
say those things and I don't mean that
in a you should ditch your friend's way
but I mean that in a I don't know I
don't have advice on how you maintain
friendships with people like that
I don't know how because I can't
so
what are your thoughts on the trend of
posting memes about the recent submarine
disaster do you think it's ever morally
okay to joke about a person's death
because they were in a position of
privilege or because they were partially
responsible for what happened so
oh
I'm gonna tread on this real lightly
what happened with that submarine
is not a tragedy
it is sad
for anyone who was close to or a loved
one of those people and for them I have
sympathy
it is not a tragedy
therefore without laying out what is or
is not okay because I don't know where
the lines are I personally am of the
mind that it is more acceptable than is
standard
um to make memes or jokes about such a
thing
because I'm kind of making a distinction
in my mind
anyone who says you can't joke about a
death
no I don't think that's true
if you want to say you can't joke about
a tragedy
I would say that's closer
you shouldn't joke to make light of a
tragedy you can still joke about
tragedies depending on how you frame the
joke because to quote George Carlin you
can joke about anything it all depends
on how you work the joke
um
but
a joke that makes light of tragedy is
something nobody should be doing if they
care at all about other people
but also this wasn't a tragedy
does that mean we can all just point and
laugh
at a certain point it's like continuing
to hit a pinata that's got nothing left
in it I think we might have hit that
point with that thing if I'm being
completely honest but that's also my own
personal taste
I I have seen some of those memes
and I can be very touchy about jokes
that make light of tragedy
and I don't have a problem with any of
the memes I've seen
what is about the aspects of trauma
leading Divinity used with the spot in
the new spiderverse movie that didn't
bother you as much as the ones used with
Wanda in Multiverse Madness oh I can
answer that really easily
um because with spot he he's
overreacting
so like
you could make an argument that what
happened to him with the collider is a
bigger deal but like the fact that he
singles out the bagel that tells you
everything you need to know about him he
blames everyone else
for his problems and the fact that the
collider happened that's not
Spider-Man's fault that's kingpin's
fault but he can't get to Kingpin he can
get to Spider-Man so he is choosing to
Target the one who he can hurt not even
the one who is more responsible for what
happened the thing about spot is that
his trauma
is debatable because honestly
up until the point where he actually is
face to face with Spider-Man and
um decides that he's not being respected
he doesn't seem that traumatized again
I'm not trying to make light of what
happened to him but
dude's just trying to rob an ATM
he's not
and like again the fact that he brought
up the bagel this is somebody who has
taken a petty slight and blown it way
out of proportion Wanda they take
genuine
traumatic events the loss of her we're
just gonna go with husband the loss of
her kids and it doesn't matter that they
weren't real quote unquote for her that
loss is emotionally true
taking that and say that that leads to
villainy I have a much bigger problem
with than
some entitled little [__] going you
threw a bagel at me now I'm gonna end
the Multiverse like those don't equate
and I can enjoy the first one because
it's making plain within the text this
is not uh this is like way out of
proportion reaction this reaction makes
no sense this is in no way a logical
extension of what happened to him
whereas Wanda it is presented much more
as
she lost her family and she went mad she
went crazy like so many people in so
many freaking movies they lose their
loved one and they just go crazy bite me
aside from the fact that a lot of
specifics of Wanda
also take me off because you know
when a parent loses their child they
don't just want a child back
like you'd see this in narrative
sometimes like and then they kidnap
someone else's child to replace them
people don't want somebody else they
want their child
and you could try and argue me like oh
well these are her kids in another she
did not raise them they are not the same
they don't know her they don't have that
bond with her
apparently losing a child is a horrible
horrible thing
and it's traumatic
and it's breaking
on an emotional level but it doesn't
turn you into a monster
so these things can stop I'm sick of
that as a trope
when you're unsure about someone's
pronouns do you find it better to
default to they them until you know
better or to use pronouns for the gender
they appear to be presenting as I have
tried to get into the habit of
defaulting to to they them when I don't
know I don't always because I'm in my
40s and I have a lot of ingrained habits
but if you're trying to build the habits
I am personally of the opinion that they
them is the better default when you
don't know
um
because I think most people
um unless they're the kind of person
who's going to be an [__] about
pronouns in the first place as long as
they're not that kind of person I think
most people will be understanding of the
fact that you went with something
neutral because you didn't know and then
they'll correct you and you can all move
forward and I think that's probably
going to be seen even if they're not the
right pronouns seen it's like oh well
that's considerate of you to go that way
here's what it should be at least that's
my thought
alrighty back to the
back to the main chat where did we leave
off
[Music]
oh I got a few super chats to catch up
on
Supreme
Omega on Baby Boomers these days it
seems like a lot of resentment toward
Boomers by younger Generations is the
meme with the meme of okay Boomer
thoughts
um
that animosity is earned
Boomers hold a disproportionate amount
of wealth a disproportionate amount of
power
um Janet like
the drop off of accumulated wealth even
like for the age for the age equivalent
ages the discrepancy between Boomer Gen
X Millennial gen Z is monstrous it's a
[__] atrocity now is that the fault
of every single individual baby boomer
no it isn't but generationally
did they screw all of us keep all the
money from themselves and burn down the
planet yeah
yeah they did and they still are
so yeah
I it is that is not unearned animosity
it should not be directed on an
individual basis
it shouldn't be unless like you know for
certain that the individual did
something but generationally
it's earned Susie thank you for becoming
a snazzy supporter I greatly appreciate
that
I got a license to Kill yeah shoots you
with a paint gun
so glad I joined thanks everyone Chad
our lovely people oh yeah we do we have
we have a good group here Susie so I'm
glad to have you here
ah
let's see
the ending of secret invasion's first
episode really pissed me off I hope it's
a fake out because I was at a watching
party to see the camera
I was watching partly to see that
character as a lead for once yeah it's a
real waste we'll see what happens
um
Supreme Omega coming in again I've just
made a habit of rolling that R I hope
you don't mind what are what's the
appeal of live-action Disney remakes I
don't know
I do I legitimately
I don't know
I don't get it I do not get the appeal
at all I don't know
unheard Sirens Incorporated ooh I like
the name
Apple
hard for you hey there happy Pride
thoughts on the style size lack of
consistency in shooting couple's doctors
looks thus far I am curious
um to see how that gets
sort of integrated or if it does get
integrated into reflecting's personality
because as a rule of thumb the look of a
doctor you know reflects their
personality in some way
so to have a doctor whose look keeps
changing all the time I will be I'm I'm
hopeful that that means something about
the kind of person he is
and I'm very curious to see what that is
now if we get there and he's got like a
super consistent super stable
personality and
um he doesn't come across as being
exceptionally worried about appearances
or whatever but he's doing that anyway
then there'll be a a little bit of a
grinding of Gears but I'm I'm curious to
discover what the numerous vastly
different outfits means for this doctor
what it says about him I'm real
real curious to find out
Suggs with a box
or Suggs with a box I don't know I happy
Pride thank you very much much
appreciated
[Music]
let's see trying to work my way down
we're almost caught up
Supremo Mega anwanda the problematic
villainization of her character is also
thinking the comics oh I know
oh I know just read House of amalonda
suffered from a lot of bad writing I
know and that really ticked me off when
some people when I bitched about her
treatment
by um
Multiverse Madness and some people being
like well you know that's the kind of
thing that happens in the comics and I'm
like I know and it's not okay there
either
oh well
I'm a licensed to slay
uh
uh I saw your final review of trial of
the time Lord I agree the valley yard
should not come back without an
extremely good reason if you know your
future you can change it ooh that's Ah
that's a good perspective I like that
Aaron oh 20 Canadian very generous thank
you Aaron hey y'all I'm not feeling the
greatest and I just popping in to say
hello so hello oh I hope you feel better
soon Aaron and thank you very much for
stopping in
the final scene from the first episode
of secret invasion was actually filmed
in my hometown I got a chance to have a
wander around the set when it was still
open oh Nifty
ah well I am going to finish this off
how
there we go
a rainbow shirt from Target won't turn
your kids gay however Natasha Leone a
salula Bankhead and the Billy Holiday
bio picture as hell well
I believe that
Wanda suffer from Bad writing in the
ultimates everybody suffered from Bad
writing in the ultimates
everybody even miles suffered from some
lousy writing not as bad
the ultimates
[Music]
anyways
thank you everybody for joining uh I
hope that you have a good remainder of
Pride
um so what have I got coming up new
um take two Doctor Who review for the
vanquishers that is out tomorrow that's
on the main Channel I'll have a review
for the third episode of the uh sixth
season of Black Mirror that will go on
on Thursday in the break room tomorrow
I'm also streaming on Twitch in the
morning I'm going to be playing Diablo 3
because I refuse to Shell out money for
anything uh related to Activision
Blizzard and I have owned Diablo 3 uh
since 20
to 11 2012. I've had it since pretty
close to when it came out so uh I don't
have to give them more money in order to
play for that though when I reinstalled
it boy were they trying to get more
money out of me
bastards anyways that'll be on Twitch uh
in the morning Saturday's video what is
Saturday's video
um I've I've been working too much today
I'm my brain is friend can't remember oh
right uh Saturday's video is
unless something happens it's probably
going to be uh just kind of a a sort of
a look at
um my own critical lens and the way in
which I approach things when I talk
about them particularly in terms of you
know reviewing them and so that
that should be it
so thank you everybody for joining me I
hope everybody has a wonderful rest of
your evening rest of Pride and uh
I'll see you around
I just tried to do a super chat I don't
know if it worked it did not come
through 255 but I need to call it a
night because I gotta get uh to editing
so thank you all very much
I hope that you have a great rest of
Pride and please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
the cavity hey